what are your thoughts on musk what he's
doing his impact Twitter
just Elon Musk period what are your
thoughts about him I don't know double
the amount of anti-Semitism according to
a report 40 percent loss of uh of AD
Revenue as of December
I I you know I find it a lot less
interesting of a place frankly uh
Twitter you know long term long term is
it gonna is it gonna end up being a I
think he's a bit of a charlatan I think
he sold a bunch of like I think like a
lot of he's got problems with his uh
with
um uh the the Tesla and I think that
like he is all you know he's admitted
that his whole hyperloop stuff was just
a way to uh crash public transportation
he wanted to crash that High-Speed Rail
he was successfully helped uh derail it
I think that's not in the best interest
of society uh so is he in that positive
to society no come on you don't think so
you don't think he's in that positive to
society no so what do you think about
all his like Twitter files and all the
showing the people like what the what
the government everybody's really doing
behind the scenes like is he a wolf in
sheep's clothing especially like with
that situation like with the AI I think
he he selectively leaked uh stuff on
Twitter files I think it's a problem
when the president of the United States
tries to silence some somebody they did
this with the Smothers Brothers Nixon
did it back in the day I mean yeah I
think that's bad but I don't think that
we see the whole story about what's
going on there oh I agree with that what
do you mean by that what do you mean by
that
I don't know I mean if you were gonna I
mean he's gonna do what's in his
interest right I mean he's going to
release what's in his best interest to
release
yeah but some of the stuff about how
they you know the New York Post story
was held back and Twitter getting the
emails and Matt taibi I'm sure you know
who Matt taibi is of course for Matt to
come and for him to say Matt's not a
republican Democrat yeah for him to say
oh I mean Matt is a contrarian reporter
and I think you know Matt also said that
he felt that uh russiagate was
equivalent to the weapons of mass
destruction lie and to me that's you
know I I think you could argue that you
know uh parts of the media got it wrong
but it wasn't even remotely close I
thought that example you don't think
Russia gate was wrong no no he's saying
the level of
I mean come on you're talking hundreds
of thousands of people I get what you're
saying no you're saying the comparison
is is a berserk too yeah yeah it was a
threat to democracy I'm saying this is
like the the Snowden releases of the NSA
I'm sorry this is a private company you
know as a business guy I'm sure your
public relations people called up local
channel 5 and said don't run that story
yeah you know that happens all the time
should the government be doing it
absolutely not but could Twitter have
announced something could have Twitter
at that time said the FBI contacted us
we're not going to give them this
information they could have and they
didn't so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign